so
i want us to go on a journey and our
journey starts
as most do with a question
how do we make programming better
it's a big question one that i realized
i've spent the better part of a decade
trying to figure out
it all started back in the early 2000s
i was building um websites in php and
and nobody had heard of rails yet and so
uh spaghetti code and sadness were kind
of the lay of the land back then
and it was me and a friend of mine
building these websites that were tens
of thousands
even hundreds of thousands of lines of
code which is crazy at the time
and we eventually hit a wall it felt
like we were constantly writing the same
crap over and over again and there just
there had to be a better way
of going about this stuff and so my
first
taste of what ultimately turned into an
obsession
came from building web frameworks
because 10 years ago it seemed like
libraries and conventions and just
raw discipline could make the whole
thing so much better
and the truth is for web programming it
did
right this is after all what rails
brought to the table back then
and clearly it had some form of success
but eventually i got tired of building
websites for other people
and despite my desperate attempts to end
up on the dotnet
mvc team i had to leave my web framework
behind
and instead i joined microsoft as a
program manager on visual studio
while i was in while i was at microsoft
i sort of moved away from this
code-oriented way of trying to think
about this problem
and instead started to think about how
tools
could make the physical act of coding
better
in many ways you can think of it i
basically was trying to fix the
mechanics of writing code
and during my time there i designed and
prototyped
dozens of things that attempted to make
that
better but more importantly i had an
opportunity to do something that only a
handful of people have ever done
and that was i got to sit behind a
one-way mirror
and watch people code and solve problems
for
weeks and it was through this that i
found
definitive proof that it is not the
mechanics
that are holding us back it's not that
we can't write code
fast enough it's that we have to play
computer in our heads most of the time
it's because we have this this
disjointed and slow feedback loop
and so i started to think about ways we
could fix that
but unfortunately uh priorities changed
and microsoft was
wasn't really the the right place for me
to look into this stuff anymore
so i left and i swore off devtools for a
while
i learned closure and
on somewhat unsurprisingly started
building
websites and web frameworks again
but then brett victor did his inventing
on principal talk
and that poked the obsession this time
it took the form of light table
a tool designed to connect us to what
we're creating
and to get rid of that need to play
computer in our heads
now in building light table we kind of
started to push
the boundaries of what our languages and
platforms were originally intended to do
right the mainstream conception of
programming just doesn't include things
like true
liveness for example and unfortunately
that's something that's particularly
difficult to kind of shoehorn in
after the fact but that's what we set
out to do
and i think we've done some really
interesting work there the latest
versions of light table really do
help reduce the feedback problem
and so with that in place it was time to
watch people again
this time with light table and guess
what
even with immediate feedback programming
is still horribly broken
i went from frameworks to mechanics
to connection and in each case
it was an incremental improvement it was
a band-aid
it was then that i realized i made a
classic
rookie mistake i set out to answer a
question
i didn't really understand
what is this really asking it seems to
suggest
that there's something broken or
inefficient about programming
but it doesn't actually say what and
even more fundamentally than that
it doesn't define terms what is
programming is it the act of writing
code
is it solving problems is it getting
something to run on a computer
i wasn't sure and to make this concrete
i needed data
so i did the obvious thing i went and
asked
everyone i knew two questions what is
programming
and what is wrong with it
i asked beginners i asked people who
have been coding for a few years and i
had the opportunity
to ask some of the best engineers in the
industry
anyone want to guess what i found what i
got out of that
nothing i did get more than nothing
i got wild variability say what
and plus one answers yes that's true no
i got wild variability and an incredible
amount of complexity
the answers to what programming is were
honestly depressing
i found out no it not once
did i hear that we are solving problems
instead
i found out that we are plumbers
and glue factories that
our lives are sort of mired in this
caveat
and frustration and weirdly enough
that was the only common thread
which i guess is interesting unto itself
right it sort of indicates that
we as an industry don't seem to have an
accepted definition for what programming
is but more interesting than that
were the answers to the question what's
wrong with programming
they tended to fall in one of two
categories
they were either so general and sort of
like
half articulated that they weren't very
useful
or they were so specific and tactical
they wouldn't apply to anyone else so
individually the answers
weren't very helpful in this case but
after talking to enough people after
getting into the hundreds of you know
people i've talked to some patterns did
start to emerge in the aggregate
and after months of doing this i finally
came
to a set of fundamental problems that we
can use to sort of
encompass all of our complaints
the first is that programming is
fundamentally
unobservable so this one has been
getting a lot of attention lately
thanks to brett and the work we've been
doing with light table
right we can't see what our code is
doing
we can't see the effects of our changes
and we can't see how our programs are
connected together
sadly that means that we can't really
observe
anything the state of the art here is a
stepwise debugger
which forces us to stop time right to
stop the world and look at a single
instant
and as most of this room probably knows
very few errors happen at a single point
right it's it's through the observation
of times passing
that we actually find them and for that
the best we have are print lines
we need to be able to observe the entire
execution of our program
forwards backwards even branched into
new futures
not just when a break point hits
and interestingly enough our
industry seems to have accepted
unobservability as a best practice
think about a line of code like this
what does it do right oops notion of
encapsulation
is by definition unobservable
now i have no idea what person.walk does
it probably does something sane like
set is walking to true but it could also
set eight carats to true and it could
have determined that i'm about to pass
out from exhaustion
i have no idea and no way to tell
we are quite literally throwing darts in
the dark
and praying that we hit the board
we can't see what our programs do and
that's a problem whether you're a
beginner or you've written
millions of lines of beautiful code
now the second point is that programming
is indirect that everything we do
is an exercise in translation even math
from which our programming languages are
born requires us to translate it into
something like this
why do we have to see that instead of
this
and that's with something that
translates fairly cleanly
what happens when it doesn't
all we get in code are symbols we never
see the real things we never interact
with the real things
just representations of them
and symbols are important and they're
powerful in some cases
but they don't have to be this opaque
they don't have to be this opaque right
if i'm writing a card game
i should see this
translation is hard using symbols is
error prone
especially when you couple it with
operations on top of
other symbols and this
indirectness this inability to represent
things meaningfully
is absolutely killing us the vast
majority of programming errors
are translation mistakes we had the idea
in our head
but in trying to turn it into code we
just forgot something or made some silly
mistake
our programs are way too large to keep
in our heads anymore
we need to be able to represent things
meaningfully
and we need to be able to directly
manipulate those representations
when we do math we should do math
in math there's no technical reason we
can't be direct
this last point is one that i think will
really hit home with this crowd
and that is that programming is full of
incidental complexity and when i say
that what i mean is that there is
all this crap that we do that has
absolutely nothing to do with solving
our problem
a perfect example of this is just think
about how long it takes
to get something simple to run on most
platforms
help we spend the better part of a week
trying to set up a
dev machine from scratch
and that's just one level of incidental
complexity sort of like a systems level
of complexity
it's pervasive at every level of the
stack right
code wise it seems the biggest thing
we're running into right now
is time management and when i say that
most people
immediately jump to concurrency or
parallelism
and that's certainly part of it but it's
a lot more fundamental than that
every time we add an event handler every
time we
write a callback we're doing time
management
we're saying at some point later i want
this code to execute
and now that our software is getting
these much more complex interaction
schemes
and we are seeing the proliferation of
these multi-core systems
we're quickly realizing that callbacks
are an awful solution
to this particular problem
every time we found ourselves manually
managing something
we've built some system to do it for us
we were handwriting binary and so we got
fortran we were managing memory
manually and so we got garbage
collectors we were trying to encode
data constraints and so we got type
systems
i think the next big step in terms of
removing incidental complexity from code
is automatically
managing time and we have to do this
stuff we have to remove these
these complex interactions that have
nothing to do with our problems
because we need to be focused on
actually solving things
not solving the problems around solving
our problems
we need to go from nothing to a solution
and the time it takes us to think it up
not the months
it takes us now so there we go
these three things seemed to encompass
everything people had told me
and so we now have a framework for
thinking about what's wrong with
programming
which gives us a way of thinking about
how to fix it
we just need to address these three
things
the scary part is though that if you
really think about it
the act of programming hasn't really
changed in
50 years now don't get me wrong i know a
bunch of you freaked out right there
we've gotten significantly better at it
right we've
we've created new languages we've
written new tools we've raised the level
of abstraction
but really that just means we've gotten
more efficient right
we just keep pushing complexity around
and lately there's been this murmur in
the community
of people starting to ask the question
why hasn't there been a
stepwise change in programming
and i think the answer comes from the
fact that every time we go and try and
fix something
we focus on some local minimum and
assume the rest is okay
we go okay we'll fix one of these maybe
two of them
and and things will be so much better
and yes that is true things do get
better i mean after all this is exactly
what i've been doing
even with light table
but the best analogy i've heard for what
this has resulted in
is teacups stacked on top of teacups
right each time we go and we fix
something and we push ourselves up a
little bit we make things better
but eventually those teacups start to
lean
if we want to really change things
we have to look at the bottom we have to
start at the foundation
and ensure that it solves our three big
points
so how do we go about that that's a big
thing to try and do
well i think the first step
is to come to a simplifying definition
of what programming is
and the one i've picked is that
programming is
data transformation
nothing else it is not setting up
systems it is not setting up databases
it's not getting things to run
it is only taking data and turning it
into
other data but instead of me trying to
tell you what a world like that would be
like let me just show you
all right so i said that this world i'm
proposing
only has data and transformation
and the use of data here is very very
important
because data has a number of properties
that automatically lend themselves to
our original goals one really nice thing
is that you need very few kinds of it to
actually
represent most of the world right a
vector with some
um with some strings in it
can represent a to-do list for example
a vector with strings and maps can
represent
html you can create a header tag and
it's got
a bunch of attributes in here like class
and it's classes greeting
we can even represent me take a map
you know i have a name it's chris
i also have a height
it's short
we don't need tons and tons of different
types of things to represent the most of
the world
it turns out that simply composing a
relatively small subset of them
you can represent the vast majority of
the things you want to
another nice property of data is that it
cannot change
you can only ever create new data right
data is fact
so if i create a map and let's say i
create a map
up here and it's got a counter as its
key and it has a value of one
if i wanted to take this and i wanted to
increment the counter
or i just want to set it to two for
example i might click here and i might
set it to two
but note that my original counter didn't
change right here's my
new value if i look at that
my original value didn't change i can
bring it back down here
all i've done is created a new value
and what this means is that data is by
definition
observable right
i can't all i have to do is capture the
inputs and the outputs
of any operation that i do and i will
see exactly what happened
there's none of this person.walk showing
me or doing a bunch of things that i
cannot see
so we have the fact that data can be
composed into lots of interesting things
that it is fact and so it is observable
another nice thing is that data is
pretty darn simple right i did
a simple operation here i wanted to
change the value of a key i changed it
from one to two
and i can change it to anything i want i
can change it to you know
whatever that number is right these
operations on data because they are so
simple
are very easy to do directly are very
easy to
start showing what's going on i'm not
writing
code that sits there and changes this
key i'm just
changing the key and it's just doing the
right thing it's capturing
the steps of what i'm doing
so let's see how you can do some maybe
more interesting things right because
data it just evaluates to itself and
that's not particularly useful
let's create a vector here that has a
bunch of numbers in it
and so we've got our little vector of
numbers and like i said it evaluates to
itself
and in this little environment that i've
created the result of any
of any step in this list is shown over
here and i'll make it a little bit
bigger i'll bring it down here so you
can see what it's
what those are right we have this vector
of 1 2 3 and 4.
so there are very finite set of data of
operations we can do on data
another nice thing that it is um there
are very few things that we need to be
able to do
and so let's transform each number in
this thing
with some new set of steps this green
box says
hey we're going to do stuff and you can
see the result of this
is a vector that just has a bunch of
nils in it and that's because if we look
at what do stuff does
it just returns nil it's not very useful
so let's make it do something really
simple
we'll just do some math here we'll add
1 to the current value
and now we can see that we have a vector
of 2 3 4 and 5.
now notice that i'm describing the steps
of what i want to have happen
how i'm transforming data into other
data
unfortunately though not very many
things could necessarily
end at in this world right we still need
to do things
that are side effectful we still need to
do things that are scary
that you know proliferate all the
problems we see in programming now
so how do we handle that in a system
where the world is only data
well the solution i have here is that we
have an escape patch
we have a way of passing data into
something that can do
the scary things for us they're called
transformers
and they're the way we'll handle state
and the way we'll handle drawing to the
screen and so on
um but up until the point at which we
need to do that scary thing we're going
to play in our world
and so to show this uh let's let's write
a little html out here right so we have
this uh list of things we have a counter
let's create
a bit of html we'll we'll create a div
and we represent html in this world as
a you know kind of a tree of vectors
right
and we'll create a button because what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a little
bit of interface that allows us to
increment that counter
so we want a map in here because we want
to set something as click
and we want to set this as a pipe
basically a
set of steps that we want to execute
when we run that or when we click on it
and we'll call this inc
so right now i have some data but and it
represents html as far as i'm concerned
but it actually isn't html yet
like i said the last step we need to do
is add a transformer
so we'll turn it into html and you can
see here i'll zoom out just a little bit
i now have an ink button right and this
is all wired up
everything is sort of time managed for
us so as i change
things everything is changing for me
and now if i click on this of course
nothing's going to happen because we
haven't described what we want to do
and let's actually go up here just for a
second we'll rename these so
this is uh add one and and this will be
increment right
and if we go in here
oops
i seem to have broken it
that's what i get let me refresh
all right let me create that little
little bit of html again
so like i said we have a div and we have
a button inside of it
with maps click
oops i don't actually want that to be
that
all right so we've got our thing here
and what we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to be able to
take this map that we had before
and increment it so
turn this into html got our increment
button back
so i'm going to click on this and you
can see we don't have any anything in
here we need to
actually give this increment to our set
of steps or you know our counter map to
our set of steps
and again if we click on this nothing's
going to happen for us yet
but you can see we now have data what is
in scope right we have data in this set
of steps that we can then work with
and we don't want to return nil what we
want to do is we want to take this
counter
uh actually no sorry we want to we want
to take this
number right and what we want to do is
we want to do some math on it so
well great we're going to take this
number and we're going to
add one to it and we're just
incrementing that's all we're doing
and this won't do anything right if i
click increment it's not like
that counter is actually going to go up
because we're not changing anything
we're just creating a new number
so we really want to do is create a new
version of our counter thing
and we'll take the old results that we
did some math on and we'll drag it in
there
and so now we have this wonderful new
version of counter
but there's no state again if i keep
clicking here nothing's going to happen
we need to use a transformer again we
need to say hey
run this program again but this time
replace that value that that i have for
counter with this new one
and so now every time i hit increment
you'll see
the counter is going up if we go back
here we can see that the counter is
there
i can go and we'll actually just kind of
add to our little bit of ui here
we'll create a span and
we'll add you know some placeholder
value and then
we'll drag in this number
oops there it goes and so now you can
see
every time i increment i get another
value
right so what we have here is a way of
playing in a world where there is only
data where we just do these simple
operations we
i like to think of this right when i
when i did the
the vectors i like to think of it as
kind of drawing the data that i want
and then i just kind of drag and fill in
bits of it
and then i feed that into a transformer
and it does the scary stuff for us
so that's great i've shown you a little
bit of state i've shown you
some sort of basic things let's do an
example that's maybe a little bit more
interesting
so my thought is we'll go through a
standard data science workflow
i've gotten some data from a database
this is from [ __ ] it's some
usage data and i need to clean it up
i want to do some math on it and i want
to draw a chart
of the results so the first thing we
want to do is take a look at what
our data looks like we have you know a
vector full of maps and it has time and
date
and what we're going to do is we're
basically going to look at the average
amount of time spent per day
so we need to get them in groups of
date right we want to see them uh you
know the the all the maps that relate to
a specific day
and we can see hey we've got this map
and it's got
all these keys for the days and it has
them there we don't actually care about
the days so much
what we really want is just the values
right so we'll get the values of that
and so now we have a data a bit of data
that looks like this
and so now we want to go over each of
these things
and do some math on them right so
we'll do each and we're going to do some
stuff you can see we're getting just
a bunch of nils that's not what we want
to be doing so let's click on it
and so here's the here's what the data
that we're currently working on this is
the last
iteration if you will and
we want to get the time out of each one
of these things
so we'll extract the value of time from
all of this
and we have a nice little
vector of all of the times
now i mentioned before and part of the
reason why i like the data science
example
is that we want to be direct right and i
made a big deal about math and i'm not a
big math guy and to be honest i find mac
very opaque
um but it's still nicer to do domains in
themselves
so when we do math in this case um
it knows that the previous value that
you were working on was this array of
numbers or this vector of numbers
and so it gives me options to do math
and math
right i want to sum them we can see the
sum here
and then i want to divide that
by the count that's the mathematical
definition for
the mean great so now if we go down and
look at what we've got
we now have this nice little vector of
numbers that are the averages of our
daily usage and i want to draw a chart
i'm not going to describe the the code
that's going to draw a chart
for me not at all i'm going to just drag
some data on here
and get a chart and i can
start modifying this chart it's
modifying underneath the structure it's
just a data structure that
represents this chart and so there you
go
a data science example straight of the
way through
and just out of curiosity i wondered how
long it would take me to do that if i
didn't have to explain it
i could do all of this in 40 seconds i
dare you to try to do that in anything
else
so the last example i wanted to do
i wanted to show you something a bit
more complex something that like
a functional oriented way of thinking
about things doesn't really handle very
well something with lots of state
how many people here have soon have seen
to do mvc
show of hands good a lot of you right
it's like the minimum
viable complete client side
and it does all sorts of little things
right i can add new to-do's to this list
i can sit here and toggle them on and
off i can
look at the i can filter them and and so
on and so forth
now the point i wanted to make is that
there's no difference
between a running program and the data
that's in a running program and the
program itself
right as i start clicking on these
things my environment is updating
because it's just representing what's on
screen and i can look and see how sort
of some of these things work if i look
at
how this remove completed button this
button down here is shown
i'm basically saying well of all the to
do's that i have match the ones where
done is true
right here i'll make this a little bit
bigger so it's a little bit easier to
see match the ones where done is true
and then get the count of those and then
find a match for the count
if it's zero well we don't need to
display a remove button it doesn't make
any sense
otherwise you know return some structure
that represents the html for that button
simple as that and so
this entire you know to do mvc is built
up in this thing if i were to build this
and the editor were a little bit better
right this is very prototype
it would probably take me five at most
10 minutes to do it
again it's removing all of this
incidental complexity i didn't think
about how to run it i didn't think about
how to set up databases i didn't think
about
um how to manage time all of these
things just happen because we're playing
in a world
that naturally fits our three original
principles
and i know one of the points that people
will probably bring up is you know
well can this possibly scale and i just
want to point out the editor itself
while simple in its sort of ui actually
has a
pretty complex set of interaction and
it's all built this way itself
so i've shown you a system that is
always observable
that is direct in every way that it can
be and that dramatically reduces
incidental complexity
but i don't think what i've shown you is
a tool
i think it's a medium and there's a big
difference between those two
a tool is something that allows you to
be more efficient
right a hammer allows us to more easily
pound in a nail than a rock does
but something like steel steel is a
medium
we couldn't have built skyscrapers with
iron it's just not
strong enough a medium allows us to do
something
that we just couldn't have done before
or that was
impractical to do before and
interestingly enough you can't know when
a medium will enable
programming is our way of encoding
thought
such that the computer can understand it
and help us with it
so imagine what what it would be like if
we were finally
free to focus on our problems
and by we i don't just mean the people
in this room
i mean everyone not just programmers
what i've shown today is the beginning
of aurora
a new medium for thought thank you